we've done it we have done it we're live
you all we are doing it big we're here
tonight
it's 5:30 p.m. in Los Angeles I have
with me my bag of almonds I'll be
needing these for the stream get a
little healthy fat healthy protein I
also have with me some water I'm gonna
need this because you don't want to get
dehydrated guys chapped lips are no good
also you know of course you got your
chapstick um bum
we're in so I'll be checking this chat
constantly well frequently you know well
occasionally okay and I'm gonna see what
you guys are up to here I have something
for you guys actually we're gonna figure
out what we're gonna make today and then
I'm gonna give you guys a whole I'll
show you I'll show you
um good to see you guys good to see you
guys always go with the almonds
absolutely um so I first of all I got to
give a shout out to what was his name
his name was mark mark help me answer
some questions for the stream here
he works at YouTube he made things he
made things get a little bit better just
a little bit better you know the
knowledge is a little bit it's cranked
up a little bit more because I'm mark so
thank you Mark all right who we got in
here guys who do we have we got David
what's up David we got to David's what's
going on Rob Robbie do Oh Robert dil in
the house everyone say hello to Robert
Robert is a fantastic stunt coordinator
stunt man he helped me with the Sleeping
Dogs live-action fight film if you guys
remember that it is a throwback to
Sleeping Dogs video game I love that
game and Robbie did I'll help me
choreograph all of the amazing fight
scenes which
basically the whole thing in the fight
scene emc monkeys they're amazing so
good to see up robbie deal it's been a
minute um who else we got Ross so Ross
Jeremy how's it going the ninja hello
sir
so I've been thinking about this over
the last week and I really want this to
be a consistent time we're gonna find a
consistent time right now it's on the
weekend
last week was Sunday this week Saturday
we're gonna find out a time that works
for all of us where we can get together
hop in to our 3d program of choice
whether it's blender 3ds max cinema 4d
maya you know whatever if you're trying
to do stuff in substance designer
substance painter let's just block out a
time once a week to get together like
this and learn more about the program
we're working on so I'm gonna I mean
obviously I'm in cinema 4d right so I'm
gonna be addition some c4d knowledge I'm
using octane as my renderer of choice so
I'll be dishing some octane knowledge
but I want to keep it pretty general as
well there was a guy in the street in
the stream yester week last week and he
was like you know let's kind of
generalize this for people who are
working in another program I think
that's great advice so let's hop in
let's forget what we're gonna do I have
I have for you guys something special
let's pull it up check this out so we
got here a list of pictures from movies
and to be honest with you guys I'm a
little afraid to like you know throw my
little finder browser window onto the
stream because who knows you know people
getting hacked - left and right these
days who knows who knows
so I'm actually it's a big list right I
got a big old list of files in separate
folders from them from different movies
like The Matrix The Last Samurai the
conjuring the apartment Terminator 2
spirited away social network Skyfall
Sixth Sense sinister Sicario 7 Saving
Private Ryan Raising Arizona prisoners
Once Upon a Time in the West No Country
for Old Men the list goes on
on guys and I have pulled images from
those movies that I love or I think I
can learn something from I put this
together when I was working at
rocketjump and I used this as a giant
database - you know reference for
lighting we had to light a certain scene
a certain way well let's pull something
from Fight Club let's see how they lit
um I don't know this scene right here
David Fincher one of my favorite
directors I love his style and his
aesthetic so it's like you know I would
oh well let's break this down you got a
little soft light in the back back here
this door is here you got like a top
light hitting these guys so let's try
and recreate that when you do your next
short so that was the purpose of this
list I loved his style
I loved his look so that would be you
know look at this like this is this is
awesome look at the wet street right
here you have these top lights these
tube lights you know a little little
everything seems natural in the
environment which I love so much it
doesn't feel like overproduced so that's
that's what I pulled from last week
right and that's how I got the spirited
away clip let's see if I can pull that
up again here we go
yes we created this yesterday there not
yesterday last week we created this guy
looked similar to this but this was our
inspiration right and you can scroll
through this whole movie and find cool
shots so I'm gonna upload this whole
database - like we transfer our Google
Drive or something and put it in the
description of this stream when this
video goes up you guys be able to get
that so I might just start uploading in
the next minute or two or ten or
whatever but let's let's see what you
guys are saying let's go to the comments
real quick hello hello
whoa chill with Brett and cliff you know
that's done we've done that so back to
the comments here um thanks for coming
guys what are we doing this stream we're
gonna figure that out we're figuring
that out we're gonna make something cool
um have I played breath of the wild I
played breath of the wild mmm breath of
the wild is like the greatest game ever
ever I listen to the soundtrack pretty
much daily and I you know I hopped in I
think I put a hundred twenty hours into
that game so good so so good um Spencer
you know I'm glad I'm doing this I'm
glad you're here what else guys what
else if you set up if you set up a
discord you can do group video calls and
whatnot yes I want to do that I do want
to do some group discord stuff and some
more personalized training with you guys
if you're interested in that you know
let me know in these comments here if
you guys are down for that um so more on
that in time as the stream grows and
whatnot song of the sea' I'm not
familiar song to see is that I assume
some Zelda stuff
have I seen the lighthouse no I have not
seen the lighthouse Matt from corridor
has gifted me the lighthouse and it is
cued up and I will watch it very soon um
what else y'all what else all right
what's your go-to way to get into into
the state for working on projects so
yeah David asked what what my what my
method is for getting into the zone for
a project well I like to get excited
about it and if it's something I have to
do that I'm not excited about well then
I just you know block out time to sit
down and do it right try and block out
as many distractions as possible keep
things quiet put on some music that you
enjoy perhaps and just enjoy the process
dive in and get going
but this is a case where you know I
enjoy every second of what I'm doing so
you know it's it all just kind of flows
it all goes so first when you figure out
what we're doing sorry guys you figure
out what we're doing
Oh shadow Colossus great game super good
game the ninja would be down for discord
sweet sweet Cole asks what project that
you have worked on in the past as
inspired you to try better was it
something that was positive or negative
man every project is a chance to get
better I forget who said this but if you
fail at something the only reason it
becomes a failure is if you don't learn
something from the failure so if you're
doing a project and I think I think it's
very important to get through to the end
put out the work of art do the thing
actually did a podcast with Andrew price
the blender guru and he actually talks
about this you know he values somebody
who can get stuff done get lots of
things done and learn from that versus
the person who spends four years on a
project which I get you know I
understand that too but get it done get
your stuff done whether you whether you
succeeded or failed in your eyes as long
as you learn something from each project
that is a good thing take some time to
write about it journal about it that's
all good stuff what else what else send
the light painting video they weren't
happy with your photos is there anything
you'd do differently
yeah I probably bring a wider lens I'd
probably bring a wider lens and a more
sturdy tripod that's what I do and if
you guys don't know the light painting
video is on corridor crew and wren
attached some lights to his drone flew
it around a dam at night and we took
some long exposure photos for that and I
can show you guys real quick the outcome
of that this is a shot here this is the
other shot and yeah I get the damn you
got the drone flying up into there it
was really cool it was an awesome
experience
all right let's let's dive in here guys
let's do this
let's get moving we need to figure out
what we're gonna do look at this
panorama that's nice that's really nice
this is a nice panorama to little train
station this would be fun this would be
a lot of texture work here which is
always a good time I love texturing this
is a similar setup you know there's some
texturing and some modeling to be done
here let's check let's check castle in
the sky real quick this is probably my
top three Miyazaki movies hmm
that would be interesting that could be
interesting
you know grass and leaves is it's not
that it's actually pretty easy with
octane and I assume some of the other
renderers
we want to do something that is doable
in you know two hours or so so we don't
want to bite off anything that's too
difficult
within that time and it at a certain
point we will get into more intense
scenes and we can maybe do one over a
month or something this would be cool
some like rock city thing this would be
cool this would actually be pretty sweet
I'm going to just dock that one maybe
I'll remember this so I'll remember this
one here if you guys have any
suggestions on what we're gonna do
that's also another reason why I think a
discord would be awesome we can start
voting on stuff that you guys want to
start making and learning hmm oh this
could be cool a little like crystal
scene a glowing crystal scene maybe oh
man what a good movie what a good movie
oh this would be sweet do these tanks
hmm could be interesting
let's keep going just keep looking for
something oh oh man yeah I'm a sucker
for like foggy atmospheric architecture
nature shots big wide angle stuff that's
awesome what else we got what else do we
have here um we have Howl's Moving
Castle I think no no no I don't have
that one mmm
let's go back to the comments what do
you guys saying here
Cornelius DOM Rick yes he is the best he
is so good oh my goodness yeah that
guy's amazing he's literally the like
the art that you see when you open
octane that's his art yeah that guy's
incredible des training is amazing love
the game hadn't beat it yet hmm
spirited away is my favorite but castle
in the sky is such a close second and
honestly Lupin Lupin third in the castle
of Cagliostro or whatever it's called
that is a good movie it's one of his
first ones let's see what you guys have
to say about the art here um the grassy
cliffs were pretty sweet the tank would
be awesome kind of music do I listen to
I'm about to play some ambient music
once we get going
um the crystal scene in the tank scene
alright let's try the let's just try
modeling a tank let's just do it let's
try modeling the tank I don't know if
we'll get a scene out of it because
there was some pretty detailed stuff in
the background there but let's let's see
what we can do um castle in the sky this
is gonna be some some texturing work
here guys it's gonna be obviously some
modeling we're gonna model this thing it
doesn't matter what 3d program you're
using the concepts will be the same when
it comes to modeling and honestly the
concepts will be the same when it comes
to texturing - it's just a matter of
like you know the short the short cuts
are probably a little different where
things are might be a little different
but the concepts are gonna be the same
so let's model this front tank and
that's about as far as we'll get
hopefully we can get to some texturing
but let's spend an hour modeling this
thing let's spend an hour maybe a little
let's spend like 40 minutes modeling 40
minutes texturing and like 20 minutes
making the railroad track and then we'll
have to figure out the background the
background might be for another time I
might just do it you know during the
week and post this on Monday or
something but let's just jump in let's
get some music going so my favorite
thing about doing VFX is you get to
listen to music you can't do that while
you're editing
so let's put on some music let's put on
some show music I don't know how this is
gonna sound for you guys but let's find
out you guys let me know hopefully it's
not too loud I'll keep my eyes on the on
the stream if it has any how about this
if it has anything to do with music
related comments like in terms of the
mix make it all caps and start it with
like 10 underscores that way I can see
exactly what's going on here okay let's
do it so we're in a new scene here
cinema 4d new scene let's model this
thing to scale right so if you make a
person and see 4d it's about the size of
a person it's a hundred and eighty
centimeters which is what two meters
let's find out it's just under two
meters so that that that's actually give
you a good idea of what a person the
size of a person so you can base your
scale off of that will make a cube and
let's just kind of get the like bottom
part of this tank going so let's see
here I'd say maybe it's that wide and
it's a little longer than it is wide so
probably something like that and yeah
it's about that tall let's roll with
that for now I'm gonna make this thing
editable by hitting C or this button in
the top left up here
now the first thing I'm seeing with this
tank let's make let's make this a
background for us so we can actually see
what's going on so I'm just going to
double click down here make a new
material and there's a whole bunch of
different ways you can do this a bunch
of different ways in different programs
but basically obviously
to get this image in here of this tank
so we can see what we're doing
boom I'm gonna make it a background
music is very quiet you can't hear music
at all no music this is very subtle
music guys it's very subtle music
it's ambient music it might be a little
too much or a little too little for the
stream but I turned it up a little bit
let me know if you can hear it if it
sounds good
if it's not the vibe I will change it
all right so our tank is in here let's
cut it let's cut this cube cube up a
little bit so now you don't get little
bit almond in my throat here a little
bit of almond dust that's why I got my
water
nice
nice
okay
all right music it's good no this is not
the blade runner soundtrack this is an
artist called
mountain shrine it's very very very
peaceful ambient music so we want to
scale this up right something like that
you got this like trapezoid looking
shape here and you see how like the
shading got all wonky
that's the Phong tag without the falling
tag the shadings gonna look in our case
Oh guys cinema for do you just crashed
wait or did it what just happened
what just happened let's save the scene
first
all right object cube tag five six
twelve present too often
as weird
it's a little weird
anyway I just adjusted the Fong angle
and it made our shading a little bit
better
[Laughter]
all right we're in guys don't worry
we're doing this so we want to start
working so okay so just quick project
kind of workflow talk here so we want to
work from the most general to the most
specific you start general and you work
down to specific just like when you're
sculpting you start with a block of
whatever and you start chipping out the
main hits right the main points and
you're gonna get more specific and more
detailed as you go it's a waste of time
it's a waste of time to focus on the
tiny details in the very beginning you
want to get if you're a painter you're
gonna get your your your big your broad
strokes down right you're gonna lay that
down first and this this goes with
everything really in life everything you
want to work from general to specific if
you're having a meeting you talk about
oh wait generally what's the goal here
what are we gonna talk about let's and
then let's get into the more specific
things so that's what I'm doing here as
I'm starting from general to specific
and I'm not really a fan of the way I
have this reference frame pulled up here
so what I'm gonna do is make a new
window let's see how would I do this
new new palette I think there we go yes
and in the palette let's see
now I'll just do it like this
so I don't really need my renderview
right now I'm just gonna shrink that
down and use this as my reference here I
could have just switched out the render
view with you know with this but that's
fine
how's everybody doing
mark thank you mark marks in the house
he helped me figure out some stuff with
this stream thank you so much ma'am
bigger face cam okay y'all asked for it
whoop
all right
we are in we're doing it
so next up we have kind of like a what's
the most next like biggest shape is
probably the top piece right that would
be a cylinder you want to scale that up
and it almost comes to the edge here so
we will bring that down it obviously
doesn't need to be this large so we'll
just have it kind of sit on top like
that and we will make it editable
we'll hit C and now we can start messing
with some points here it does have the
top ring is smaller than the bottom and
so I'm just gonna do a loop selection
I'm hit ul on the keyboard get that hit
T to get scale and I'm oh my goodness
that's not what I wanted to do all right
here's a good here's a good thing it
took me a minute to figure out you see
how the top piece is separate from the
rest of the cylinder well for some
reason I don't know why that happens but
it does you just need to select all your
points and optimize it you can right
click hit optimize or it's a you Oh as
the shortcut so again i'ma hit ul loop
selection hit T scale it oh my goodness
scale it down and there we go you can
see it's working properly now and on top
of that it looks like there's another
cylinder so I'm gonna duplicate this
cylinder hold ctrl and drag to duplicate
and move at the same time I'm gonna hit
T for scale and scale this down once
more
now you guys can see I'm I'm building
out this shape right and all I'm doing
like I used to get really intimidated by
modeling because I look at something and
I'd be like man there's no way I'm gonna
be able to do this it's so detailed it's
so complicated
how am I possibly gonna do this but if
you start general and work your way down
to more specific you will surprise
yourself I promise so challenge yourself
you know if you guys are modeling this
tank with me on the stream then you know
obviously we're doing this one together
but if it's anything else challenge
yourself to start from general to
specific there goes the almond dust
again
y'all asking for shoutouts kinda shouts
we talking about here
john-paul bernard no that's not I got
that wrong John Paul Bernal shoutouts
thanks man
a PC what PC do I have I have it's a
custom PC I have a gtx 1070 graphics
card I think I have like 24 gigs of ram
I have a thousand watt power supply I
have like an I don't know an an into a
size 7 processor or something I feel
like they're they're all called i7 i I
don't know a friend helped me build this
thing man he helped me put this together
I got a lot of fans a lot of cooling I
have an SSD before my C Drive I have
like a 2 or 3 terabyte hard drive for
storage and then I have like an external
drive as well I've never done the keto
diet to answer your question Bowden but
I have intermittent fasting and I like
it a lot I have a lot more energy
throughout the day can I shout out
Dwayne the rock Johnson of course I can
shout out doing the rock Johnson guys
let's get back to the VFX man all right
so what's next what's the next pretty
obvious thing we have a cylinder right
here boom this guy let's make a cylinder
and we're gonna may need to make it a
little bigger and it looks like it comes
right up to this point here like it's
all point part of one structure we'll
scale that down a little bit and
obviously you guys can see that the
angle of this this shape right here this
shape right here we need to get right
because you can see it here right and
generally that looks about right
but what's telling me it's wrong is this
cylinder here
so I'm keeping it an eye an eye out for
this stuff right this cylinder goes
into this main piece at about the
halfway mark
so I know this piece needs to intersect
completely with this main piece at about
the halfway mark completely so I'll make
my adjustments accordingly ul for the
loop selection and I'm gonna try and get
there we go so I have those points bring
them down so now we're talking
that's about the halfway point for that
right and if we were to draw an
imaginary line from this cylinder down
to the bottom of this thing they are
about in line so that means I need to
make this I need to scale this thing up
so that let's get rid of our guy
I need a scale that bottom point up just
enough so that this line here matches
with this plane down here hopefully that
makes sense to you guys you'll see what
I'm talking about in two seconds there
it is there's a line that is drawn
basically from there and now it's
intersecting completely I still think
this looks taller to me this ours looks
a bit fatter so we're gonna want to work
the shape of this a little bit more
something like that yeah
I'd say that that feels about right
maybe these top pieces are a little
large
let's get those guys right so bring
those down a little bit and this is very
similar to drawing guys I don't know if
any of you guys have ever drawn before
but when you're drawing and you're
drawing a you're referencing something
you always want to see like well you
want to capture the essence of it right
and everyone's face is different let's
say you're doing a portrait of someone's
face
you're gonna take note well how many lip
lengths is between their nose and their
eyebrows you know I don't know you can
count it you can kind of see it usually
there's about an eye space worth of
space between their two eyes you know
how much space do they have between
their bottom lip and their jaw these are
all things that you have to be asking
yourself when you're drawing and it's
the same thing with modeling when you're
using a reference
I'm happy with that
awesome a I'm glad you guys are enjoying
this really really appreciate you guys
ok so that's looking a little wonky from
the side here let's let's bring in the
let's bring this in a little bit so
we're gonna select the loop there and
I'm hitting T and we're just kind of
bringing in a little bit I'd say that
that feels about right
scale this up a little bit more and
again we're starting general and then
we're getting detailed so we'll come in
here and we'll start rounding out these
edges and everything what is next guys
what is next we have this turret piece
here so that to me looks like a cylinder
rather no I'm sorry yeah no it is a
cylinder I'm gonna bring it up we're
gonna rotate it this way and then we're
gonna rotate it this way and scale it
down to about there then bring it
forward something like that
yeah hopefully this is making sense to
you guys we're starting general and
we're getting to the specifics so you
can already see this pieces tinier than
the big one we started with you know we
have to cut this piece out and add the
turrets there so we can get to cut the
cutting out portion in a minute here but
let's keep going with the general vibe
of things so right here we have the
cylinder if I want to spawn something at
the point where the cylinder is you can
hold ctrl down make another cylinder and
it'll spawn right there
I hit R for rotating grab the x-axis
hold shift and the the what is it the
degrees to which you rotate the thing
it'll snap right so if I hold shift if I
hold shift you can see it goes 10 20 30
40 verses just trying to eyeball it
you'll be there for you know until next
Christmas so it looks like this thing
tapers down it starts large and gets a
little smaller but again you know we
will deal with the details of that a
little later we want to get the general
placement and feeling right so it's a
little lower on this thing we'll control
drag and we'll get that second piece
there and move it back a little bit so
already we're getting closer right we
have two spheres down here it looks like
so that's an easy one right we'll make a
sphere we'll pull it forward scale it
down
and work it into place
now if you want to get it exactly right
you know on that other side other than
just eyeballing it what you can do is
look at the numbers down here you look
at your coordinates and then send them
afford either down here so we're looking
at you know we move it on the z axis and
we can see the z axis is shifting this
number down here it's shifting so we
know the z axis is the number we need
right so I'm gonna I'm going to copy
this number and control drag and paste
the number in and take the minus and
delete the minus so it turns still
positive and there you go
now in cinema you can select multiple
objects and make changes across the
board on everything so I'm gonna select
both of these spheres and drop the
segments down to I don't know 18 because
they don't need to be super super high
poly right and you can see how both of
them shifted if I want them to be a
hundred they're both gonna change so
what is next now we're getting into a
bit smaller detail here so it looks like
okay you see this cylinder here with
this turret it's mirrored on this other
side because I see a turret and I see
the piping for this thing right here
so what I'm gonna do is model this out
and then just use the cemetry object
here or the cemetry tool rather to
mirror it on the other side how's
everybody doing everyone doing all right
thanks for sticking in building out a
tank any any requests any questions are
you guys doing good should we keep
moving on
so there's an easy way it's a model and
then you can make things really
difficult for yourself when you model
and you guys will see what I mean in one
second but before we get to that let's
have some sort of like organizational
setup so I'll just make a null I'll call
it tanked and I'll drop all the stuff
they make up this tank into that folder
so we have like this top turret piece so
we can call that let's see it be like
that
and these four pieces right here let's
say these five pieces we can right click
group objects and we'll call that turret
and you can actually get the anchor
point of this turret piece I'm hitting
l2 bring up the axis tool and we can
kind of eyeball it for now but we want
to get it right in the center so that
way you know when you animate this tank
it rotates properly what's next we have
like the hull of the tank and that would
be the main you know they're basically
everything else so I'm gonna select
those parts and group them we'll call
that the hole and now we have kind of a
little organizational structure here and
organization is key you don't want to
get lost when you're working that's the
last thing you want to do so let's keep
going let's check the check comments
here
glad you guys are like in the stream
awesome awesome
doing great awesome
what's the second head behind the main
one second head behind the main one I
don't really talk about I did not know
doing great
making one of my own in blender right
now awesome keep it up we got music
requests I'm gonna keep vibing on this
for now I'm going to change it in a
second I didn't know I needed this much
until I didn't know I needed this in my
life until now
JJ cinema thank you thank you thank you
milkman 3 who knows maybe maybe at some
point
okay interesting sorry for back seating
but disable your live viewer it's using
your g-man true words never spoken truer
words never spoken thank you thank you
neo neo keto thanks dude
what else we got ooh test not the recipe
for the Super Bowl tomorrow nice
I think blenders awesome you guys should
totally use it um what movie personally
think has the best visual effects raw
ones that blew away I mean honestly I'm
not a superhero fan and on a big
superhero fan not a big Avengers fan but
you know those effects are amazing
recently though I did we did at corridor
a VFX artists react on Bollywood movies
and I saw this movie called zero and my
goodness the VFX blew my mind they still
hurt my head to this day so give that a
check when you you know just at some
point how long did it take to make all
those cardboard guns in the old videos
man that was so much fun
it took a couple weeks man but it was
the best glad you guys are on the stream
glad you guys are here all right Nick
Nick AM enjoy your hot dogs and JP and
Meena vlog yes we'll do a photography
tutorial at some point I know that on
the corridor a crew I will be doing a
film photography tutorial with Nick so
that'll be fun well let's hop back in
man let's get back into it um let's get
this top piece looking nice yeah what do
you guys think let's get in here so we
got some rounded edges on this thing so
I'm gonna move this turret up here and
start dealing with the main piece
so I'm gonna do a loop selection for the
top and the bottom and you know what to
be honest like you can do this a couple
ways you can bake in your bevel you know
this way you're baking it into the
polygons here which totally works
or you could if you hold shift and go up
to these deformers you can use the bevel
deformer and that is actually a cool way
to keep you know if you want to undo
something you have that option so if in
the bevel deformer it brings up this
little window and we're we have a we
have a few options so the first thing
I'll do is I'll check this box you use
angle and the use angle box is you see
how it's beveling everything we don't
want to bevel everything we want it to
bevel only certain points so I'm gonna
check that box and you can see that it's
at an angle threshold of 40% if we crank
that down it's gonna start getting
everything but since we told it no we
only want to do angles higher than 34
degrees or more intense than 34 degrees
then you fixate on those exact edges so
we'll offset it like maybe 5 maybe 10
and we want a subdivision of 10 that's
up to you guys however however many
polygons you want start with 5 I think
that's good you see it gives it like a
little rounded edge and a note that I
have heard time and time again no edge
is perfectly sharp even a knife has a
beveled edge and that's actually a
really really good tip for you guys for
anything CG based right first off when
you bevel your edges it catches the
light in a certain way I mean it catches
the light period you're gonna get that
nice like that Sheen off the edge of
something if it's perfectly sharp you're
not gonna get anything
so you want to bevel all your edges and
by doing it with the bell deformer
you know that gives you guys the chance
to experiment to experiment with it and
undo it or or you know let's say we want
this to be a little bit more intense or
you want it to be you know a little less
intense so that's a way that's just like
a little tip right and it's cool because
you can drag this little bevel deformer
on to that guy and if you hold alt when
you drag something it will it should I'm
sorry control controls the the key you
want
so I control dragged it onto there we
can bring down the offset a little bit
yeah that's just artistic taste at that
point sweet next we have some like
pieces cut out of this thing so it
almost looks like a pill shaped piece
right here so we can bring this out and
we're gonna cut out this little piece
here with a baleen and we did that
yesterday night mr. cotton yester week
for the bridge that's how we cut out the
bridge so now this is kind of getting
detailed but we're on the turret you
know we're gonna start working on the
turret and man there was a way to like
snap the angle of this exactly to the
angle of the the turret piece here and
for the life of me I cannot remember how
to do it that's definitely one that
we'll want to look up because it is a
really nice tip real quick though before
I do that I just want to
[Music]
let's see for those of you guys who
don't know where I'm going with this
basically what I'm doing is I'm gonna
use this object to cut out a hole from
the turret and the hole will be the
shape of this object here
all right so this is going to go back
into there
we're going to want to get it in line
this piece here
this totally looks like a like a vitamin
like a like a daily vitamin piece
there's a better way of doing this I
know there is but right now that's what
we got to do so we're gonna want to
throw that on that side too so what I'm
gonna do is let's see we need to move
the anchor point of this piece to the
center point right here so we'll go into
like top view and I'm gonna hit L for my
anchor point and I'm hitting W to switch
between world and local for the anchor
point and that's super helpful I'm gonna
switch to world and I'm just gonna move
this to that point there will zoom in
and we're just gonna eyeball it and I
know last week we talked about using the
the axis tool but I think the axis tool
is only relative to the object itself
and in this case we want a very specific
point that we're trying to get it to so
now I can hit R hold down control and
move this to the other side so we'll
have two symmetrical holes we're gonna
cut out from this thing we can take
these two objects and we can connect
them and delete basically meaning that's
one object now that's considered one
object up in our hierarchy up here and
again with the boolean we did this last
week a boolean is basically going to
take one object which is our cylinder
here drop the bullying down into our
turret null
we're gonna drop this in there so a
minus minus B gets us this look right
here and it looks a little wonky it has
these pieces coming down so we'll do a
couple things to like alleviate that I
think you guys can see what I'm talking
about we get these weird weird points so
first in the bullying op the bullying
options will check the box for creating
a single object will hide the new edges
and that took care of it
hiding new the new I just took care of
it and actually if you take this bevel
and you drop it ooh that didn't work
that didn't work there's a way to bevel
everything
none of those are working
I wonder if let's see we just gotta get
the hierarchy right so in the boolean
object there's the main piece and then
there's those like pill shaped pieces we
want to bevel the whole thing so I think
what you could do is group that so it's
in a null and then you bevel oh that
looks at Rosh you see bevel that let's
see this is not working
hmmm maybe it's cuz okay so the bevels
working from here you guys can see that
but it's not getting those bottom pieces
it's something down here
so I wonder if pulling these things a
little further out will help now that
kind of made it worse
I'm gonna stick back to what we were
doing hmm
how do we get those edges
Guillermo yeah there's totally a world
where these these streams take place a
little sooner another reason why I want
to get that discord channel going is so
that we can all like have a place to
talk and just put some ideas out and
figure out the best time that work so
everybody Ross thanks for stopping by
man I hope you get a chance to watch
this after the fact once it goes up to
my channel thank you salmon I appreciate
it man
so alright
right now I'm I'm trying to get I'm
trying to do some problem solving and
that is another thing you do a lot of
when it comes to visual effects it's a
lot of problem-solving let's say the
client or the job requires you to really
bevel this edge you have to bevel that
edge or else you do not get paid or you
do not you know you got angry bosses or
something whatever you gotta get that
edge beveled and for the life of me
right now I'm having a tough time with
it so how are we gonna do this how are
we gonna do this so the the bullying if
we hit C and make this editable it turns
into just a straight-up
object which is kind of like the brute
force method and I can throw another
bevel in there and you know check the
box so that it's only hitting let's say
90-degree angles
and the offset is 0.1 but it's really
messing up down here
it's it's really not having a good time
down here I think it would just be a
matter of like redoing the bullying and
doing it with something that isn't
rounded on the backside I think that
would be the way to do it
[Music]
cuz that's not it's not looking good for
us right there
I think for the sake of the stream I'm
gonna move on just because we only have
a limited amount of time here if I were
to do this again I would do it with
instead of a rounded backing here I
would just do it with a flat back and I
think that would help the geometry clean
itself up a little bit because it's it's
this it's this thing that is screwing
with us so I'm gonna break my own rule
here I'm going to I'm going to not bevel
that edge at least for now
oops got a call hello Marcus in time in
time
all right we're back in
so yeah I'm gonna leave that as is for
now let's let's keep moving on let's get
this thing modeled there's a railing up
here let's get this railing so the
railing we will do with splines so a
spline is basically like you know and
after effects you have your your pick
points and your your point tool and your
pen tool and all that stuff and that is
basically the same thing but just in 3d
so what we want to do is kind of get
like a semicircle because it looks like
there's a semicircle vibe going on right
here and there's a cycloid and I wonder
if a cycloid can kind of kind of become
what we want it to become we want to
become a semicircle not this like
mushroom looking thing hmm no none of
these are really what we need that's a
full circle and it looks like it just
opens up - oh there it is there it is
nice okay so I'll bring it around a
little bit more than half all right
let's just say 180 for now and we have
this let's scale it up - it looks like
it's on the top of this thing so we'll
get it right there see it's right it's
chillin right there and now it's really
as easy it's as easy as doing a couple
steps here so we have this piece this is
our main piece that we want to kind of
wrap around we want to throw it in a a
sweep nerve and the sweep nerve is
basically something for the cycloid to
go into to make it thick it's gonna be
thick right and it's not doing it yet
that's because it needs to know how
thick so you grab a circle object or a
circle spline and you drop that circle
spline into the sweep object as well and
man that is a very very large rail there
so we're gonna scale that down I'm
hitting T and there we go you guys can
see it's like a nice little nice little
rail that's a lot of polygons we don't
need that many so I think the option for
that would be in the sweep object I
don't know yet okay so I know we want
fill it caps and a fill it cap is
basically a beveled edge so one
centimeter is fine for that and we can
you know just just that little bit of a
bevel is fine it's such a small detail
that's gonna catch the light from the
Sun up top and reflect it nicely so that
that's really all you need with that but
let's just try and get the poly count
down and I think that is okay that's not
yes that is in the angle for how small
of a detail this is that could be fine
but if you guys are trying to go high
poly with everything then you know you
can bring that down a little bit and a
uniform there we go so this here is
basically how the the subdivisions are
spread throughout your spline right or
your sweep object
I like uniform because it keeps
everything uniform and I think the lower
the number
yeah the fewer the polygons and I but I
do want to get these down the horizontal
ones down so is that a oh there you go
cool it was the cycloid so they work
together to kind of give you that look
now they have little guardrails that go
down so what I'll do is now we can go in
here guys and we can start placing
individual cubes but my goodness that's
gonna take years so what we're gonna do
is use a cloner object you guys want to
get smart with the way you do things you
want to save as much time as possible so
you want to use a mograph cloner object
and what that is gonna do is clone a
certain object in a certain way so what
we want is to make one of those little
railings and it's okay if it's a square
here in this case or a little rectangle
because again it's such a small detail
and it depends it depends on what you're
doing this for if you're doing this for
like the Avengers then you know you're
gonna want to do it legit but but also
maybe maybe you don't need to you know
so it looks like we got this ten
centimeters
at 10 centimeters we can probably go
down five centimeters I'm just getting
the scaling right getting it into place
so that's kind of the vibe like that
right but we can see how it arches in
and in fact this sweep object or the
cycloid rather we can scale it up so it
goes outside beyond the bounds of you
know this edge just by a little bit so
that we can have those points come in so
we have our cube here it's generally in
place we want to drop that into the
cloner disappeared it's probably inside
the tank
[Music]
yeah there you go so it looks like one
giant stick but that's because it's
three smaller sticks stacked on top of
each other that's because it's linear we
want to change the mode from linear to
radial and we're on the wrong axis so we
want to change the plane from XY and I
always get this wrong I always get this
wrong I have to guess every time so XY
means it's going left and right up and
down so we want it on X Z yes yes right
right sweet we'll scale that actually no
we won't scale it
we'll start messing with some of these
settings so the radius is what we want
and we know we want a higher count of
them so you guys can kind of see where
we're getting at here we'll move this
down and we only want it on the front
half not all right that we wanted on the
back half not the front half so I think
there's a way to do that yeah I think
you can just do it like that
so we can just set the end angle to 180
and rotate this whole thing around a
little bit we can remove the number of
them say there's like 15 and we just
want to make sure our edges are
symmetrical right so now we want to
adjust the rotation of these things so
you can go into transform and start
messing with the rotation boom that's
what we want right there
and then we can scale it down a little
bit and there you go
that's like a little platform set up and
we can use that same system that we
built and and again guys keep in mind
you can replace these cubes with
cylinders if you want to be more
specific with it and here's actually
let's talk about that bevel right we
want to we want these to catch the
lights so you can check the Phillip box
there and which kind of turns them into
cylinders already but we'll just do
something small we'll do like 0.5
centimeters
you only need one subdivision and
that'll give you enough to catch the
light they're awesome so that could be
our like we'll use that time and again
here and you know to duplicate that
process for this thing right here so
let's um let's just do that while we're
at it we have our sweep and our cloner
we can group these together and call
this railing
and let's get the anchor point in the
center of that
huh so we want to adjust that a little
bit
you know I think I actually had it yeah
it was right it was right before sweet
we'll just bring it up cool so we can
control drag this over to the other
little turret thingy so it's right in
the middle of that and we will scale it
down bring it down and we'll rotate it
90 degrees and that's basically the idea
with that you know we can adjust the
amount of objects we're cloning in the
object tag here and just do like maybe
ten or something and we can maybe
thicken up the railing perhaps just a
little bit by going into the sweep going
to our circle and scaling that up so you
have full control over all this stuff
and same for the cube the cube can be
like that's that's that's the benefit of
keeping your things editable when you
you know when you bake it and when you
at sea or when you hit this button here
when you make I'm sorry I have it I have
it backwards my phrasing is backwards
you want to keep your things like
tweakable and in cinema 4d to make it
editable it is saying like oh you hit C
and now you can like mess with the
individual polygons and points but in
this case we have control over because
it's a primitive and we can control the
size of it we don't have to I think you
guys know what I'm saying let's um let's
keep moving on here
hey I really appreciate you guys giving
each other some advice in the in the
chat here CGM Studios dishing out that
Maya information that's awesome that's
super cool
thank you thank you
hand placing objects gives you better
sense of organic placement okay for sure
using those modifiers will look like
what it is more robotic placement Oh
Casey Edwards what's up Casey I'm gonna
be seeing you later tonight man thanks
for stopping by
okay to address the robotic placement
check this out guys about to blow your
mind look at this
alright the rails are robotically placed
I hear ya that is a thing that is the
thing I mean this is a machine so you
know you have been going for it but
let's say you wanted it to be a little
randomized how do you randomize these
pieces dirt with a cloner you know you
don't have a randomized option but just
kidding you do check this out so I must
like my railing I'm gonna select Mike
Lohner right because the cloner is
driving the things these pipes here we
want to randomize these pipes so you're
gonna want to go to and cinema4d if you
get a mograph effector or random and
automatically it's working look at that
it randomly places these things all
around if it's not working for you you
can go to cloner and hit the effectors
tab and drag this randomizer boom into
there
and you can see it's working now when
you click the random effector I love
this thing so much it has its checked
for position right now
so each pipe is being displaced by 50
centimeters on the XY and Z randomly in
space you can set that to 1 1 1 and you
get kind of an organic look here I can
go 3 3 3
and each one you can see here is a
little randomized and it's the same with
rotation - if you do 360 across the
board it's gonna look crazy you know it
could look like some cool spikes but if
you just do one one one you get a little
bit of that randomness which is super
cool and I think I'll keep it and you
can throw the same effector you don't
have to make another random effector you
can throw the same one into this guy
down here so that will be your other
railing you're gonna go into there
select the cloner you see the effectors
tab drag and drop the random and you can
see how they're just randomly moved
about I think it's awesome good note
very good note okay let's keep it up
what else do we have we have these like
viewing window pieces here these all
look like little viewing windows and
honestly I'm starting to get some vibes
here like you see these you see how the
cylinder is separated by these lines
same for the top up here now we could we
could get those lines by just doing a
low polygon object so I can replace the
cylinder with another cylinder and
instead of making it editable right out
the the gates here
we can say okay this cylinder is only
six polygons
let's go 12 polygons around I lied let's
go eight and now when you make that
editable you can scale the bottom up
alright to get oh it's doing that thing
again
remember when you scale it and it's not
attached so just hit control a first
select all and then you oh is the
optimize button you could also just
right click and hit optimize down here
you can also hit shift C and type in
optimize and click it and it'll work so
you l for loop selection I'm gonna hit T
for scale and we're gonna scale that
back up
we'll bring it down
[Music]
and we'll hide the original don't delete
it just in case and yeah there you go
you can see we kind of have like a more
geometric armor-plated shaped cylinder
you can throw the same bevel modifier
that we had on this main one here we can
control drag that down to our new
cylinder and give it the same treatment
and you can see how it kind of rounds
things out a bit and I'll tweak it so
that we're only going with like you know
five five centimeters three centimeters
even and we don't need as many
subdivisions
and you can double these up too so like
you see how it has this top bevel here I
like that but let's drag another one
down and let's change the settings on
that we want to get those edges right
there snap the Gregorian chants guys I
think we got a skip these Gregorian
chants
all right let's keep going guys thanks
for sticking in so we're trying to get
this second bevel we want to subdivide
that by zero offset it only by three two
and I don't know is there a way to do
this it's not having that like weird
triangle piece the limit thing is kind
of working but where is the limit
options so now I'm in now I'm in the
zone where I hadn't gone this far guys
this is new ground for me here oh you
can do a per selection we can use this
so what if we just wanted oh I bet you
it has to do that it has to connect the
dots some way but I'm cool with that
look I'm cool with that look I don't
think we're gonna get this whole thing
modeled by the end of this stream guys
this might have to be a two-parter or
maybe next week's tutorial is on
texturing this thing so you guys might
have little bit of homework
get your tank modeled and then we'll
come back next week and texture it but
we still got an hour so let's keep going
alright so we want to cut these little
viewing windows out so that's gonna be
cylinder and we're gonna loop select all
of these guys and we want to extrude
well actually let's make some cuts so
imma hit KL and you see I'm where these
little windows are I'm gonna slice it
there and I'm a slice it there and
actually you know what I'm gonna I'm
gonna do this a little differently I'm
gonna slice it there knowing that I want
to select this loop and from here if you
hit M W on the keyboard you're gonna use
you're gonna get
to the extrude inner tool here you can
also get to it by right-clicking and
hitting extra dinner and if we start
going right here it's not going to give
us what we want that's one giant viewing
window we want individual viewing
windows so if you uncheck preserve
groups each one will be its own deal
right and it's as easy that boom there
you go we'll hit we want to extrude
these back so that's MT for extrude you
can also right-click and choose extrude
you can also hit shift C and type
extrude if you don't know where it is
and select the option there so we're
brought up with some options on the
right but if you just click and drag
will get we're already extrude and stuff
and to go the next level to actually
make it look like you know it's inset
into this thing we could do another
extrude inner that's MW we'll scale it
up a little bit and we'll extrude it
again and that will actually get you
like an inside piece you see that it's
like we're kind of inside it's it's set
in to the armor and that will kind of
add right that'll add a little bit you
can go next level with it and do exactly
what we just did but to the extreme
so mwx drew dinner will really extrude
it and then we'll extrude it back and if
I toggle the sub or if I toggle the
ambient occlusion you can see it's inset
into the tank there Oh gross what just
happened guys what does happen
let's undo that for a second yeah you
see what I mean here it's inset into the
tank which is cool because that'll be
glass at some point let's get our bevel
down right that doesn't that look right
so this might be the case we're like you
have to actually just bevel it as
opposed to using the deform ER because
you know or honestly or we could use the
selection so let's let's try it I've
never used it before
we'll do a edge selection across the top
there and we will say we'll go to select
set selection and I'm hitting ul on the
keyboard to do a loop selection you
could also go to select and hit where is
it loop selection you well so we got
that we went select set selection and
next to the cylinder there is this
little tag here selection tag and that
is what the bevel deformer will
reference so we'll drag that into the
selection and hopefully fingers crossed
it's only going to bevel that part sweet
it works it works that's awesome and I'm
hitting n a or n B or NC or nd to switch
back and forth between like viewing
modes you can also get that through
display and a and B and C and D you guys
can see that it's helpful for viewing
your stuff
let's see what um let's adjust this
selection so what if we want to include
these pieces - what would that look like
because I do want to bevel those to an
extent
stood against election set selection
cool and I think we have to read drop it
or oh I know why it's because uh we have
to adjust our angle threshold and yeah
there you go
what kind of have like a little little
setup there that's nice we can go step
further and bevel these edges so I'm
hitting ul once again and I'm holding
down shift to select all of these edges
and now we'll do the same deal we'll go
select set selection will throw in we'll
just control drag this bevel and we will
reference our new edge selection here in
our bevel we'll drop that guy in there
and then now we have in theory we have a
second bevel option so let's let's see
let's rename these so the first one is
called the big bevel the other one's
called little bevel and we'll just
relink those there we go now it's
working I think it was just having
problems referencing the same name
awesome this is looking really cool
so that's a way that you can you know
bevel an object and mess with an object
without actually messing with it so if I
turn those off we're back to normal
so it's fully editable that's really
helpful because if you have again a
client or the job asks oh we want the
edges to be a bit more beveled you can
just come in and make those changes
rather than having to remodel this whole
piece saving you time time and money
dude
yes Casey's getting some love Casey is a
fantastic composer he he's like my go-to
composer same for corridor he's working
on some big stuff he did the the Devil
Trigger song for Devil May Cry ok he's
legit man he he's all about that theme
he'll get you that theme and carry it
through your whole short he did the the
music for the floor is lava he did the
music for I believe Dead Island was the
first project we were we worked on
together he did the music for baby on
board he did the music for a lot of
corridor shorts casey is legit very
legit so that's cool you're in you're
crazy I'm excited to eat extra sharp
cheddar cheese with you later tonight
alright let's keep going let's see if we
can't get this top turret modeled by the
end of this stream got another call Ben
I'm a let me get back to you soon then
we back to you son I promise all right
so let's get this top tier modeled by
the end of this stream and then we all
got homework right we got a we got a
model our tank because we're coming back
next week and we're gonna texture the
crap out of this thing you guys you guys
can see how much time this takes right
it's a lot of work I'm snacking on some
almonds man I got my bag of almonds
right here it I don't leave home without
it
they're from Modesto from the source
almonds from the source snack healthy
y'all snack healthy all right shout outs
to almonds tell us about all those
almonds yeah okay we'll deal guys we'll
deal with those rivets soon cuz you can
see it's a little rivets here lots of
good detail on that we'll get to that
last I think I'm done with this top
piece I'm done with the railing let's
get into the gun let's do the gun so we
have
we have this cylinder right here this
piece right here we need to cut out a
chunk from that so I think the easiest
way to do so we can do it with like a
bully
bullying again we can cut a piece out of
that
so let us let's try that I think that's
the fastest way to be honest here
so we'll scale this down scale it in so
generally that is the shape we'll want
to cut out so we'll grab a boolean
object oh here's a here's a tip select
whatever object you guys want in this
case it's our cylinder here they were
gonna cut into if you hold alt in cinema
4d and then select your bullying and let
go the object that you had selected will
automatically become a child of the
object the new object you selected so in
this case the cylinder has become a
child of the boolean object next we have
the cube
we'll just want to drag that underneath
and for the longest time I always got
the the order wrong like what comes
first the cylinder or the you know or
the cube and I think it was Nick on
greyscale gorilla he said it's a minus B
so it's a your cylinder minus B your
cube and ever since he said that I you
know always remembered the order so
thank you Nick grayscale gorilla they
are the best oh just the best alright so
guys the back again with the almond dust
man let's take care of that everyone
grab some water
hydrate stay healthy
Johnny Boz in the house Jay Boz good to
see you man thanks for joining us we're
modeling a tank today Jay Boz next week
we're texturing it so dude thanks for
joining man thanks for joining I hope
you got blender open I hope you got
cinema 4d open I hope you got something
open I hope you got a pad of paper and a
pen and you're drawing a tank whatever
it is let's take this time to get better
at our creative pursuits once a week
hopefully its daily hopefully where
we're all taking an hour a day to get
better at our creative pursuits but this
is the chance we get to do it together
so let's keep it up all right
let's hide those new lines that's
looking good that's looking real good
let's see if we can't bevel this thing
so I'm going to group it and then I'm
going to hold down shift and then hit
bevel and now when you hold shift that's
the opposite of Ault when you hold alt
you're making the object get selected a
child of the new object when you hold
shift you're making it a parent you just
have to play with it just play with it
you'll see what I mean we're going to
work the angle limit there let's say
we'll do two and five so we got a nice
beveled edge there and you can see how
this in this case it worked for us
Springer but in this case it didn't
because the geometry was all wonky and
that this is a good example of what I
would have done better with this one is
I would have used a flat backed piece
like I did here I used the square it
didn't create all these unneeded
polygons back there there's a bunch of
unneeded polygons here I might fix that
later but for the sake of the tutorial
in our time my precious time we're gonna
keep moving on what else do we got
we need these this like turret thing
this thing's awesome this thing is
awesome so this will be easy we'll
select this guy and it's pretty simple
really it's just getting smaller and
smaller in little stacks here so
honestly a really easy way of doing this
is moving this back control dragging it
forward scaling it down control dragging
it forward scaling it down and there you
go we could have gone in there we could
have modeled a whole bunch of stuff but
honestly that's not really necessary
right now let's just keep track though
of these pieces so one two three there
you go
let's group it and call it technically
this is a barrel right now we do need to
make the top one editable and that's
because we need to like inset this piece
because you know that's it's it's a
barrel there's something inside of here
so I'm gonna hit ul for a loop selection
this is one I use all the time we want
to extra dinner so that's MW now this is
a case where we want the opposite we
want to preserve the grips so we'll
check that box bring that in we'll make
it nice and thick and we'll extrude it
back that's m/t or you can right click
and hit extrude well you know all the
all the stuff is here you just right
click and all the stuff is there and
let's push it back all the way back
there you go honestly I kind of want to
undo that a little bit because I want my
extra dinner to be a little more intense
I like that that's cool and then we can
honestly we can do another loop
selection hit T for scale and oh it's do
that thing again where it's disconnected
right I don't know why it does that
control a to select everything bonus
points for if you guys remember the
shortcut you can right-click and
optimize that's UO is the shortcut for
optimize ul for the loop selection hit T
scale it down and it's scaling we want
to bring the back of this thing up a bit
more so let's do that
I'm not too concerned about the back of
that thing because it is you know you
don't you don't see it
there you go um I might adjust that a
little bit it looks a little wonk and 3d
is a lot of testing pushing and pulling
seeing what works what doesn't
it's a lot of experimenting and that
goes with any any profession any craft
it's gonna be it's gonna be the same
thing a lot of dedication to just
patience - you know experimenting and
testing and solving problems and if it
doesn't work keep going so that is the
bottom piece the top piece is very
similar so I think I'm just going to see
here where is the top piece this is why
you want to organize your stuff because
this is gonna get really intense guys
give me a lot of objects so turret okay
we have we can name that base and then
we have let's see this is like the
barrel all of this stuff Plus that is
the barrel
what I just do I think I'm messing
something up
that's our top piece that's our barrel
our actual barrel that is our like
barrel fixture here's the piece we need
boom so similar process we'll make sure
it fits in here and let's take a look at
our reference you have a main piece
that's kind of back in here I'm looking
at that and then you have another piece
that comes out it looks like a scope
we'll scale that down bring it forward
again and once again we will make just
the top piece here editable because
we're gonna want to mess with our
honestly honestly weed mmm let's see
let's try something select the cylinder
hold ctrl make a sphere it's gonna be
put in place right where the sphere is
scale it down move it to the end and
let's let's actually make this editable
and then flatten it and that'll get you
like a lens right
and if we wanted to we could make this
cylinder editable let's just do it I
already know it's not gonna work
properly so control a yoooo to optimize
ul for loop selection we're gonna extra
to enter that be MW
when you want to come in and then we
want to extra back MT and that will get
you just a little bit more detail on the
lens there so it's inset right it's
inset so there you go we're getting
there let's go through and just make
sure this stuff is beveled no no
straight edge left behind we want to
bevel all of this crap so what needs to
be beveled this cylinder I guess let's
rename this let's rename is to what it
is this is the scope so in cinema you
can see here when it's like when this
icon is the actual primitive object that
means you're still able to tweak things
about the object that you wouldn't be
able to if it was editable so there's
kind of like two stages of editing all
your settings over here you know you can
adjust the radius the height you can
adjust how many segments it has which
isn't easy to do once you make it
editable you can also adjust the bevel
or the fill it or fillet or whatever you
want to call it and that's what we're
here to do so before we do this let's
select all of the editable or the non
edit that's so confusing I got to get my
wording right let's select all of our
primitives that we still have the
ability ability to control so there's
one there's two there's three we've just
selected all these
and you can do batch edits so we'll do
this all at once well make sure they'll
have fill it's will make it a one
centimeter deal and we'll make it zero
segments sure but isn't that cool like
you can get that edit at the same time
now the only two we can't do it are
these these ones back here just because
we made them editable but what we can do
is let's go to the barrel and we'll find
that cylinder piece here we go you can
see how the icon is a little different
we don't have the ability to adjust the
fill it but if we hold shift we can
throw that bevel object in there
deformer in there and we'll use the
angle we'll make sure it's just that
little piece there adjust your slider so
you're only getting the edges you want
and we'll do the same deal it's 2
centimeters and maybe that's a little
little much one centimeter three
subdivisions these numbers guys they're
probably gonna be different for you so
you don't have to follow exactly to the
number just follow to what feels right
what looks right that's all I'm doing
and I'm going to duplicate that and
throw that bevel deformer into this
little scope piece so I'll control drag
that into that and you can see boom
there you go now it looks like there
might be some extra detail like some
rivets in there we'll do rivets last now
this tank is full of a bunch of detail
pieces like this little little rectangle
these little bars and stuff and let's
just build out a couple of those and
we're will almost be done with this top
piece here we'll get to the rivets and
that'll be that so basically we can
select an object up here ctrl click and
will spawn a cube right there
bring it down and we'll shape it out
as we get that extra detail and it looks
like it's rotated so that it is flush
with this thing here and again I
mentioned this earlier in the stream but
you see how this axis here you see how
let me change let me change this song
this is getting goofy guys let's see
what's the vibe right now let's let's
throw on some breath of the wild music
alright how's everybody doing we're on
our last 30 minutes here working on the
top of this tank I hope all y'all are
working on your tank or draw on your
tank or or clay modeling your tank or
working on any other project I just hope
you guys getting something out of this
I'll check that in a second back to this
little quick tip here basically you see
how my axis is changing right here I'm
hitting W and you can see this toggle is
changing up here and basically what
we're doing is switching between local
angle and world angle what I mean by
that is this is the local angle this is
the local angle of this cube it's going
that way it's going that way I think it
makes sense to you guys right based on
how this object is rotated but if I hit
W and I toggle this coordinate system
the world object system then it goes up
and down based on the world that's in
the world is around and that is so
useful my goodness I use it so much so
keep that in mind when you're moving
stuff around so we got this piece it
looks like a multi-tiered thing so to me
that is it's kind of rounded so we'll
bevel these edges will throw that will
check the Philip box
and it's a pretty large bevel on that
[Music]
but it's only beveled on the how do i
how do i phrase this let's see let's
uncheck that and let's make it editable
by hitting c or this button up here and
we're gonna do a loop selection an edge
selection we'll get these four corners
and we're gonna bevel those so imma hit
em s on the keyboard that's your bevel
and you bring it in like that
and let's actually adjust we want like
three subdivisions on that that feels
right to me
see how before we were getting this edge
too we didn't want that but in this case
right we wanted a large bevel on those
edges but we want a tiny bevel on this
edge because it's still sharp so what
we'll do is we'll throw hold down shift
and we'll throw in another bevel deform
and we'll check the angle threshold and
you can already see how it's it's
working properly let's do like two
subdivisions on that and like that looks
like a nice chunky piece there you know
it exists it's in this world its bevel
it has beveled edges it's gonna catch
the light really nice it's gonna utilize
the textures really well around that
edge and it looks like there's like a
top plate piece on this thing so what
we'll do for that is control drag this
cube up and out and we'll want to select
the local orientation for the axis and
just scale it on the Z and this will be
like a little armor plate piecing on
an armor plating piece on top and you
can see how our bevel was messed with so
we're gonna want to go in there and
tweak the bevel so it's right yeah like
that and then there's rivets around this
thing so let's deal with the rivets real
quick actually real quick just for some
extra detail let's clone it one more
time scale it down even further and just
place it right in there that that feels
thick you know that's some that's some
armor right there that's some detail to
it detail goes a long way you just need
to know when is the right time to add
the detail sometimes it's a waste of
time
sometimes it's not in this case who
knows maybe it was a waste of time but
it's fun you know and if it's a chance
for you to learn if you're gonna go and
add that detail go the next level do it
because word that's what we're here to
do we're here to learn right you get to
a point where you realized oh I don't
need to add that detail there I don't
know time have enough time or I don't
have I don't need to because you're not
gonna see it it's gonna be on the back
of the thing whatever um let's check
these comments um let's see I remember
learning graphic designers that used
Mac's are known to be generally
preferable to ones who use windows yeah
whatever it's a preference thing right
it's a preference I use a PC because I
like playing video games what else but
you know Mac's are great Macs are
fantastic at that point be picky about
your clients if they don't like the
software you use don't work with them oh
man
okay yeah if your clients are trying to
tell you what software to use that
that's so rare I've never had that
happen all the matters is can you get
the job done if you can that's all that
matters that should all be all that
matters unless you're working in a
pipeline we're like a studio uses Maya
and you're transferring files back and
forth with people with the same program
that's when it would matter
um let's see
local versus global for the win yes
absolutely
see GM studios have a bunch of resources
I can share with you guys for learning
substance modeling movies lighting etc
not sure where the best place to send
you them are CGM studios um let's see I
really want to get this discord thing
going and I will have it ready for the
next one I promise I will have the
discord chat or group or whatever ready
for the next time I do this stream next
week we can dump all of our assets in
there
I still haven't forgot about this list
of pictures from different movies as a
reference I'm going to upload that to
Google Drive and include a download link
to it in the description of this stream
when it goes on my page so watch out for
that I'm eating almonds you know you
guys keep asking I'm eating the almonds
right there good for you
keep your almond intake upright am I
gonna use this in a video yeah I'll
probably make something with this just
for Instagram though it's not really a
corridor thing but I'll make something
out of it I put this time into it let's
let's let's do something with it
sheamus it's going man it's going thanks
for asking
o CGM you're on a 7 K user 3d disc order
can you help yeah what's the best way to
get in touch man um let's see
hmm um CG I'm here me I'm on Instagram
it's underscore poni sure underscore on
Instagram and just send me a direct
message and we'll talk there we'll
figure it out you also you were also the
one who made the gizmo duck 3d
four-quarter awesome man heck yeah thank
you that's so funny
what a wacky video Jay Baz discord yes
okay we're gonna figure it out guys
we're gonna get discord going for next
week we can drop all of our cool assets
in there and figure out what we're gonna
do a little earlier then just figure it
out here so we can maximize our time but
speaking of time I got about 20 more
minutes let's let's figure out these
rivets let's do the rivets so the rivets
are really tiny and there's a lot of
them and very quickly they will eat up
your memory so we need to be smart with
this stuff you can do it in a lot of
different ways placing them individually
is out of the question do not do that I
mean you can but let's figure out a
better way to do this first off you need
the rivet you can make it a sphere you
can bevel it you can make a detail but
there's so many of them and they're so
tiny you're not gonna be able to tell so
let's keep this as simple as possible
let's scale this thing down and that's
about the size of a rivet maybe a little
flatter and you could just do squares
you could just do squares but I don't
know let's take it one step further
let's replace this with a cylinder scale
it way down and the cylinder is going to
be it's gonna have six sides and that is
our rivet right there do you even do
five sides whatever we'll do six
hopefully we can adjust this thing
because we're gonna keep it like this we
can adjust the sides from here we're
gonna want to throw it into a cloner
object I believe I think there's a lot
of ways about going about this process
but let's try it with a cloner object
right now if you hold alt and go to
mograph hold the button the mouse button
down let go on cloner it's gonna get
plopped into a cloner we're gonna want
you see how it's going straight up into
the air like that that's a linear cloner
you see it under mode you're gonna
change it to a radial like we did with
the railing and it looks like we're
gonna want X Z orientation once again
and all right so first off we want to
get these rivets going down the side of
this thing so they're oriented in the
wrong direction we're gonna want to go
to transform and rotate them 90 degrees
technically it'd be a little different
it'll be a little bit more than 90
degrees because this thing is kind of
like bowed out but we'll get to that in
a second let's um let's start stacking
this so how would we go about doing that
[Music]
maybe it's a
is it a grid array no it's not it's not
a grid maybe it's a honeycomb we just
need to find the right the right
orientation right for this thing we want
to bring down the size width I think in
the height
this is tough what is the best way to do
this we could do a multi cloner you do
an object cloner and put them on the
points let's go back to radial see and
this is the problem-solving that the
effects takes a lot of it's a lot of
problem-solving a lot of troubleshooting
a lot of googling so let's see we want a
count of like 8 I think right because
that's one one per corner and then we're
gonna want to let's scale this up a
little bit let's work the radius and
bring it let's see how are we gonna do
this
this is getting tricky so we want it to
like open up and get wider as it goes
down and this is one piece right like we
could we could come in here set that
duplicate it do it again make it bigger
we could do that but if let's say there
there might be a better way to do this
so let's see yeah we're gonna clone the
cloner so I'm holding alt I'm gonna make
a new clone ER and you can see how okay
now we're kind of getting we're getting
that shape here we'll bring down the
amount there and we'll add it a count of
like 8 and you can see how this is gonna
fit over this but we need the the bottom
to bow out and I think oh man how would
we do this it might be a step modifier
steps I okay wait maybe all right so
it's not that it's not that and it's not
that step size
single value cumulative and at this
point I'm messing around and seeing what
works we basically want that but with
scale we want that but with like the
radius so would it be and if you guys
have any ideas on how to do this I am
all ears if you have any tips on how to
do this type in all caps in the in the
comments so let's see let's see
[Music]
maybe it's like a i'ma try step modifier
so that would be effector or a step
effector I'd be under mograph effectors
step okay okay okay I think it's gonna
work you can see how it's kind of like
build out like a bell it has a little
bit of like movement to it and that's
based off of this curve right here so we
want to make this a linear a linear
curve so I'll set that to linear it's
doing what we need it to do
it's just upside down and little
backwards so what if we switched those
okay guys this is working now let's
let's see yeah we'll just bring that in
and then we'll bring our cloner down and
we're gonna rotate the cloner a little
bit and now we can start messing with
the detailed orientation of these things
so we can go into our first cloner and
mess with the rotation of all these guys
so they're flush I like the size of
those I think they're cool I'm gonna
make just a new solid and reference this
gray here and throw that on the cloner
just so we can like things blend in a
little bit but that's that's basically
it I think technically they're getting a
little bit bigger as they go down there
but it's such a small thing I think it
works
I'll get that flush yeah yeah I think
that's awesome and then you can
basically we can group this here and we
can call this bolts and we'll duplicate
that for this main piece so let's do
that
let's um let's make sure our anchor
point is right we'll control drag this
down and we want the radius to be larger
so that would be I believe our first
cloner we would adjust the radius so
they come out and then our second cloner
would be the amount of like how high
they stack so maybe this would be like
15 they'd stack 15 high and we bring the
radius in so that you know they're
actually touching right here and then
let's work the rotation so that the
rotation is right and that would be the
first cloner under transform we'll get
that right yeah and we still want to
work the radius
try 162 161 that's the sweet spot let's
go down to the bottom and look at our
step modifier and work the strength so
that the bottom touches 18 that's the
one that that's the number that works
for me and it looks like we need a
little we need a bit more
so we'll go like or rather than adding
more let's scale up the amount at the
spacing between them so it'd be like 15
now 11 maybe 12 we'll bring that whole
setup down and we will do instead of 8
bolt segments I mean you guys get the
idea here right it's basically we're
just going in here and we have we set up
our bolt system if you will and it's
just editing it based on what works for
you know each piece we're putting it on
and because of our adjustments we have
to adjust further so it'll be like
radius will tweak that
well did you guys hear that card is
totally peeled out 156 and then the
bottom the step modifier at the bottom
will change that so 22 yeah that's the
idea
you know and then we'll go across the
top right here because you can see them
across the top we can take out bolts
here so a count of maybe like oh sorry
wrong one right here we can do like ten
but then we're going to adjust you know
so every time you adjust you have to
kind of tweak further so that's the only
downside to this but it is saving us Ram
it's it is saving us time as opposed to
like having to individually place these
things and then you know for these right
here these detailed ones we might have
to individually individually place
segments or like stretches of bolts but
you guys are get the idea man
that's it that is it thank you guys for
joining
I really really appreciate you guys so
next week hopefully hopefully I will
have this tank modeled and looking cool
for you guys next week we'll come back
and we'll texture the crap out of this
thing we'll make it look really nice
keep working on your tanks keep working
on whatever you guys are working on
honestly like you don't even have to do
a tank you new whatever this is just
this is just fun for me whatever you
guys want to work on you can do and next
week we'll be talking about texturing
we're all texture this guy things to
look forward to so I will have a link in
this video here once it good once the
video is over on my page I'll have a
link of all those like movie stills for
you guys to download in reference you
can take a look at all those use them
for whatever you want let's see I'm
gonna have a discord chat ready for all
you guys next time so we can have a
place to like
you know have a little chat and talk
about stuff a little further we can do
maybe some like private one-on-one
streams or something for VFX and oh if
you guys want to support me in the
meantime I do have a website and it is
not VFX based
yet I'm gonna come out with a VFX
website in the future but I do have my
photography website it's noise grain and
light comm it's a place for me to put
all my photography here from around the
world China Beijing Taiwan Indonesia
Canada you know I've been to a whole
bunch of places a lot of good times
Japan actually twice and you can go into
the collections tab here and see the
different shots from all the different
countries I've been to
a lot of it is film photography a lot of
its digital photography feel free to
contact me here on this website if you
guys have any questions on photography
or anything and then I do have a store
where I am selling prints these are
super super nice prints really
high-quality archival print quality and
I wish I had one of those prints here to
show you guys but yeah you know I try to
make the prices as cheap as I can for
everybody I ship them out pretty quick I
sign them all sometimes I put incense in
them I put music recommendations on the
back of everything so yeah that's the
site if you guys want to you know help
support a little bit in the meantime I
want to get some VFX assets for you guys
in the future as well but yeah come back
next week we're gonna do a whole thing
we'll texture that tank we'll make it
look nice and yeah let's see any other
comments any last little comments here
before we close up J Boz sweet heck yeah
dude
the Prince man Jay Bob's got a print it
looks nice looks super nice Zorin that's
so funny dude that's awesome
um anything else anything else guys I
think that's pretty much everything I
really look forward to doing this again
this has been a lot of fun a lot a lot
of fun so I will see you guys next week
I'm gonna go eat some extra sharp
cheddar cheese with Casey he's coming
over in a minute so until next time
peace